[موسيقى]
العمل من غرفة الطعام محشورين
في مساحة صغيرة لست وحدك
لمنع الأوجاع والآلام
تقترح تقارير المستهلك أن تبدأ
بكرسيك ، حيث يسمح وضع الجلوس المثالي
لقدميك بالراحة على الأرض بينما
يتناسب الحوض والظهر مع
يقولون إن ظهر الكرسي سيساعد في
دعم جسمك وتجنب
الضغط غير المبرر على ظهرك ، وتأكد من أن
شاشتك في مستوى عينك بحيث
تحدق قليلاً نحو الأسفل باتجاه
منتصف الشاشة ، وقد يساعد ذلك في
منع إجهاد رقبتك  وتساعد أيضًا في
منع صداع العينين الجاف وعدم وضوح
الرؤية ،
فلا تضع هاتفك بين
كتفك وأذنك مما يشد
رقبتك للخلف والكتفين ، استخدم سماعات الأذن
أو ضعها على مكبر الصوت إذا كنت تعمل
من السرير أو الجلوس مع الأريكة.  مرة أخرى
على جدار الأريكة أو اللوح الأمامي مع
وسادتين ، واحدة أفقية خلف
أسفل ظهرك والأخرى عموديًا لدعم
عمودك الفقري وأخذ فترات راحة تسمح
لجسمك بتغيير أوضاعك بشكل متكرر  r
الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا آندي جيثر
[موسيقى]